in this episode I will spoil Star Wars
it's just for Malthus my producer I'm
not actually gonna do that but net
neutrality has come to an end which
means that Armageddon is upon us all the
children will die the seals will wither
in the Sun all of the terrible things
will happen or maybe not I will explain
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
it's a Friday so we're all in a good
mood here around the office and hence
the the last Jedi reference I've not
seen it so I can't spoil anything about
last Jedi except I do know that Luke's
mechanical hand from Return of the Jedi
has now been replaced with a flipper
like a dolphin flipper that's that's
what I know about the movie so if the
spoiler alert he has a flipper for a
hand okay but in other news net
neutrality has come to an igneous end
and everyone is losing their mind we're
all going to die captain dogs will live
together the world will burst into flame
you'll have to choose between your two
firstborn children as to which one will
be sacrificed to AOL and which one will
be sacrificed to Verizon you will have
to make these decisions at least this is
what we've learned in the last 24 hours
after a set of regulations that really
didn't end up doing much well it's just
abolished by the FCC we'll get to all of
that but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Birch gold so
right now does it seem like there's a
lot of uncertainty in the world well it
should and one of the reasons it should
feel like there's a lot of uncertainty
in the world is because we no one knows
what the heck is going on any of whether
we're talking foreign policy whether
we're talking natural disasters or
whether we're just stopping the markets
where it seems like Bitcoin is riding
the roller coaster if you want an actual
asset that you know is going to have
value no matter what happens right so
you can't hack gold then you ought to be
looking at precious metals it's one of
the things that you ought to have part
of your portfolio in Birch gold makes
sure that can happen for you they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group right now and you get a
16-page free kit revealing how gold and
silver can protect your savings and how
you can legally move your IRA or 401k
out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA to get your no cost
no obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash Bend that's birchgold.com
slash been go over there check it out
ask all your questions and then when you
feel secure to invest then go to my
friends at Birch cool birchgold.com
slash bend use that slash pens that they
know that we say you okay so everyone
lost their mind yesterday because net
neutrality was repealed whoo now here's
the truth I've talked about net
neutrality here on the program a little
bit I was not in favor of net neutrality
I didn't interview with a chip I the
head of the FCC the guy who is most
responsible for getting rid of net
neutrality and I think
his answers were relatively good there
are decent arguments on both sides from
net neutrality there really are I'm
gonna try and be as objective as
possible about this and lay out the
argument for one side and then lay out
the argument for the other side and then
tell you why I come down on the side
that I come down basically here's how it
works
you order your internet from Verizon
Verizon is an internet service provider
Netflix buys data from Verizon so that
Netflix can actually be on the internet
and then you pay so that you have access
to Netflix right this is all common
sense this is how the internet works
well Verizon isn't as an ISP or or
Sprint's as an ISP is Sprint's and I
speak Comcast is an ISP and some of that
some of these ISPs they compete with one
another and one of the things that they
want to do is they want the ability to
privilege certain content above other
content when it comes to charging them
the reason for this is that basically
right now Netflix for example takes up
an enormous amount of bandwidth for
whatever ISP it is it is working with
and that drives up the price for
bandwidth for smaller providers so it is
quite possible than an ISP may launch
that wants to charge Netflix more per
byte of data and therefore drive the
price down for the other people who are
using the Internet right or it's
possible that the ISP may say to Netflix
listen you want to load faster than
other sites you can pay us a premium all
of this is fine right I don't see a huge
problem with any of this the only
problem with any of this is if there is
a monopoly or oligopoly and here's the
argument in favor of net neutrality so
let's say that you only have one
internet service provider in your area
the reason that you probably only have
one internet service provider in your
area is because a lot of local
government regulations make it difficult
to build an ISP in order to lay down
broadband you actually have to have
government rights of way and a lot of
local governments will put conditions on
the various companies that want to come
in so that creates a sort of oligopoly
situation the idea here is let's say
that there's Comcast and Comcast owns
Netflix so let's just say they bought
Netflix and they want to help Netflix
but they want to hurt Hulu so they
slowed down artificially the speed on
Hulu encouraging people to subscribe to
Netflix instead of subscribing to Hulu
right this is the great fear that
Comcast is basically gonna strangle in
the crib competition - it's vertically
integrated companies and this is not an
idle worry in a monopoly situation you
theoretically could do this so the anti
net neutrality people will say listen we
already have anti competition
regulations in place right you can
actually prosecute monopolies that are
acting as monopolies the FTC the Federal
Trade Commission can crackdown the FCC
can crackdown on this you don't need to
basically mandate that all traffic be
treated the same or be charged the same
because again maybe you want to charge
your Netflix more because it's taking up
more bandwidth maybe you want to charge
the pornography company that's taking up
an enormous amount of bandwidth on your
computer more maybe you want to do all
of those things so everybody who is in
favor of net neutrality says well the
ISPs shouldn't be allowed to do that
when you buy an internet uplink then you
should basically get all the pages at
the same rate and for a given price but
the truth is that you're actually
redistributing cost right let's say that
my grandmother doesn't use Netflix well
her internet price the price that
Comcast is charging for her is actually
going to be higher than normally would
be if for example they could divide out
Netflix and have you pay a subscription
fee for a faster internet service
against Netflix faster and she's
actually subsidizing me because I'm
using Netflix and she isn't she doesn't
have to use very much data I have to use
more data and there's a sort of free
distributive mechanism that happens so
these are the two arguments one is that
Olga Polly means that the government has
to come in and regulate the ISPs they
don't strangle Netflix or YouTube or any
other any other outlet that they want to
strangle and people against net
neutrality say well if you actually want
to foster competition in the ISP space
if you want a proper distribution of
cost then you actually need to let
competition take over now in order for
competition to take over it's not enough
for the federal government just to get
rid of net neutrality the federal
government also needs to encourage all
of these companies to start investing in
local areas and local governments need
to start encouraging all the ISPs to
invest in building new broadband
networks okay so those are the arguments
the reason I come down against net
neutrality is because I don't think that
the the answer to oligopoly is more
oligopoly once you enshrine the idea and
create barriers to entry that every
piece of data has to be treated the same
then what is the comparative advantage
of a small start-up company as opposed
to Comcast the answer is none but it can
be very difficult for them to compete in
that market that is why you see all of
these small ISPs actually in favor of
getting rid of net neutrality the
companies you see in favor of keeping
that neutrality our companies like
Netflix they don't want to pay more for
that fast tolling on the Internet
highway okay now here's the truth no
matter what happened with net neutrality
the internet was not going
to be radically different it was not
going to radically change because of
Comcast were to start strangling hulu in
its crib there would be competitive
ramifications for that in the
marketplace people would start out to
start opting for Verizon instead of
Comcast there would be an effort by
smaller ISPs to get in the market
competition would become a thing and
it's very interesting to me that a lot
of the same people who are deeply
concerned with big corporations like
Comcast strangling various companies
they don't like aren't seemingly
unconcerned about Facebook or YouTube or
Twitter strangling political positions
they don't like right Twitter routinely
knocks people off line for things that
Twitter doesn't like YouTube will D
monetize videos they don't like my
friends at places like ladder with
Crowder and Dave Rubin they've been
demonetized Prager University have been
too monetized by YouTube I don't see the
same people who are complaining about
net neutrality complaining the YouTube
is not treating all content the same and
they're all in favor of all content be
treating the same being treated the same
when it comes to their favorite outlets
but when it comes to their favorite
political views they have nothing to say
I'm pretty consistent on this I think
YouTube has the right to crackdown on
videos it doesn't like they have the
right to do it they're wrong to do it
but they have the right to do it and I
think ISPs have the right to do it
similarly I think competition in the
marketplace keeps a lot of these
companies honest okay so with all of
that said there's this weird idea that
was going around that the end of the
internet was gonna happen yesterday CNN
actually headlined end of the Internet
and yet strangely their article appeared
on the Internet
after this after all of this had
happened right but the level of outrage
and insanity was so high so I want to
show you some of these tweets and some
of them are totally crazy
this one is from GLAAD the Gay and
Lesbian Alliance Against Defamation they
literally tweeted the repeal of net
neutrality is an attack on the LGBTQ
community okay so number one anytime
GLAAD headlines anything you could just
get rid of the first four words and
simple and put any other four words in
there Republican tax cuts are an attack
on the LGBT community dog catchers are
an attack on the LGBTQ community if you
think that net neutrality is a specific
and attack on on gay people I don't know
it's tell you there are lots of straight
people who use the internet gang and
that seems like a bit of a stretch to me
Banksy whose most well known for
basically graffitiing other people's
property he tweeted this nonsense out
Twitter $14.99 a month
snapchat nine
ninety-nine a month YouTube 1990 and a
month Netflix $9.99 per movie Google
$1.99 per search if you don't want to
pay extra for your favorite sites you
need to be supporting net neutrality
this is incoherent okay its incoherent
you know why netflix can't charge $14.99
a month cuz no one will pay 15 bucks for
Twitter okay you know why Twitter can't
charge that cuz no one will pay that
money for Twitter no one on earth you
know why Netflix can't charge $9.99 a
movie because no one's gonna pay $9.99 a
movie for the stuff that's on Netflix
it's not going to happen because there's
a thing called Amazon right this this
whole idea that that Google is gonna
charge $1.99 per search well if they
want to make Bing the biggest thing on
planet Earth they could do that I
suppose but this makes it makes no sense
at all it's absolute utter horse crap
but this is the sort of alarmism that
you saw on the internet yesterday we're
all gonna die you're gonna have to
sacrifice your dog to the gods of
Twitter if you want to maintain your
Twitter account chuck schumer tweeted
out if net neutrality is eliminated the
internet may start to resemble a toll
road but the highest bidder is cruising
along private fast lanes while the rest
of us an inch along the single traffic
took public Lane number one Chuck
Schumer is the senator from New York New
York is a lot of toll roads they work
really well toll roads are actually kind
of great one of the reasons toll roads
exist is because number one they
actually clear out a lane okay toll road
to actually relieve traffic on the rest
of the lane usually a toll road is added
to it is not subtracted from usually
don't just take one of the lanes of the
highway and call it a toll road usually
you build an extra Lane and then that's
a toll road and so all of that money
goes toward upkeep on the highway and if
you want to pay for the toll road then
you get a fast lane if that were really
true then toll roads on the internet
we're fine Netflix would pay a little
bit more for their internet speed you
might pay a little bit more if you use
netflix a lot and you pay a little bit
less if you use netflix a lot which
seems fair to me frankly if you don't
understand how this works think about
bundled cable basically net neutrality
is bundled cable you have to pay one
price for everything and if you get rid
of net neutrality even according to the
worst case you know scenario people but
the idea here would be they get to pick
and choose which is PDUs based on the
services that it provides number one I
don't think that's actually gonna happen
but even if it did happen I'm not sure
that it's the end of the world well I
did in that the alarmism didn't stop
there Bernie Sanders did the same thing
he said net neutrality is gonna be the
end of the world first of all the last
time Bernie Sanders
use the interwebs was 1997 he used a
dial-up AOL modem Bernie Sanders I'm not
sure knows what a computer is yeah but
here is Bernie Sanders the socialist
talking about why net neutrality matters
despite the fact that the Internet is
the greatest the greatest and freest and
most open market in the history of
mankind and he opposes open markets here
here's Bernie Sanders a disastrous
decision it impact every American
it will give huge advantages to big
corporations of the small businesses the
big media companies over smaller media
outlets we've got to do everything we
can to defeat this thing in the courts
and defeated legislatively okay so the
other time I going to the courts first
of all Democrats can't go to the courts
okay administrative decisions like this
are not appealable if Bernie Sanders
wants net neutrality he can damn well
push for it in Congress which by the way
is where it should have been pushed for
in the first place this is not a
regulatory decision regulating the
internet like like the DWP under title 2
regulating it like a telephone company
under the under the title 2 makes no
sense legally if you want to do this do
it through Congress in a second I'm
going to explain I mean I'm gonna let
really add your PI the head of the FCC
explain why it is that that net
neutrality is a bad idea but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at filter by comm so you don't
think very much about the filters the
air filters in your house well you
should because you know what happens
right every five years somehow you start
feeling sick you look up at your air
filters and it turns out they they're
just filled with garbage and mold and
dust and yuck
well that's why you need filter by comm
right now go to filter by comm you get
the best price on top quality filters
shipped within 24 hours plus free
shipping Americans spend 90% of their
times of their time indoors according to
studies the air you and your family
breathe contains up to 100 times greater
air pollution levels than the air
outside yes even in places like Los
Angeles filter by comm we'll send you
the size you need within 24 hours plus
free shipping plus all their filters are
manufactured right here in the United
States they can ship any size in any
quantity and you save 5% when you set up
auto delivery and then you never have to
think about the air filters again so
instead of you just waiting until
somebody says god it smells terrible in
your house now the air filters arrived
it reminds you just the fact that they
arrived reminds you to replace the air
filters and you never have to worry
about it again because it's not
your vent size is constantly changing
once you register once everybody knows
right there the company knows which
filters to send you changing your HVAC
filters is easy it's worthwhile it helps
keep you healthy business owners also
love filter by comm because they're
really busy and don't want to think
about air filters and you can order
whatever quantity you need no matter the
size of your office so cleaner air lower
utility utility bees health bills
healthier you it's the fastest way to
order any size in any quantity at the
best price free shipping filter by comm
today check out filter by dot-com today
okay so yesterday or the day before I
had the chance to speak with a I
adjure pie is the head of the FCC and he
explained to me I asked him specifically
about the big question if there's an
Oleg Appa Lee right if there's only one
Internet service provider in your area
then shouldn't net neutrality be a thing
right shouldn't we force that oligopoly
to treat all Internet traffic the same
so it can't strangle off Hulu or Netflix
or YouTube or whichever app it wants to
in favor of its own content here was a
I explaining
two different points number one I agree
that we need more competition and that's
why over the last 11 months that I've
been in office as the chairman of the
FCC we've undertaken a number of
initiatives to promote a lot more
competition getting more wireless
spectrum out there for wireless carriers
to use making it easier for smaller
fiber providers to enter the marketplace
getting the next generation of satellite
companies into the marketplace to
provide an alternative to the
terrestrial folks so we're promoting
more competition that way number two
ironically these heavy-handed internet
regulations imposed by the FCC in 2015
take us in the opposite direction they
make it a harder it's already hard as it
is for a lot of these smaller internet
service providers to build a business
case for deploying Internet
infrastructure especially in rural and
low-income urban areas these regulations
make it even harder the last week alone
I've spoken to small Internet service
providers that nobody has ever heard of
from Minnesota Montana who said that
these regulations make it harder to
raise capital to build a business case
for deployment and actually spend the
money in the time and the statistic that
a GOP really cites here and the one that
makes the most sense we can stop him
there well what makes the most sense
he's talked about this he says that
among our nation's 12 largest Internet
service providers domestic broadband
capital expenditures decreased by five
point six percent or three point six
billion dollars between 2014 and 2016
the first two years of the title to era
the point being that as soon as Net
Neutrality hit all of the ISPs basically
assumed that all the competition was
wiped out the major ISPs assumed that
there is no reason for them to spend any
more because new regulations would be
coming down the pike forcing them to
spend and so they stopped spending on
broadband they stopped doing upkeep on
their broadband and making it faster and
making it better a free market makes
competition better
he explained yesterday and as this thing
was repealed 3-2 he explained his net
neutrality decision and again everyone
went not something he's been hit with an
enormous number of death threats over
this whole thing
returning to the legal framework that
governed the internet from President
Clinton's pronouncement in 1996 until
2015 is not going to destroy the
Internet it is not going to end the
Internet as we know it it is not going
to kill democracy it is not going to
stifle free expression online if stating
these propositions alone doesn't
demonstrate their absurdity or Internet
experience before 2015 and our Internet
experience tomorrow once this order
passes we'll prove them so simply put by
returning to the light-touch title one
framework we are helping consumers and
promoting competition broadband
providers will have stronger incentives
to build networks especially in unserved
areas and to upgrade networks to gigabit
speeds and 5g this means there will be
more competition among broadband
providers it also means more ways that
startups and tech giants alike can
deliver applications and content to more
users and short is a freer and more open
Internet okay so you know this is the
case that he's making people make the
opposite case but one thing that is
clear is though it's not going to
destroy the internet and so CNN's crazed
headlines about this and the Democrats
craze talk about this it's a wild
exaggeration how a regulatory issue that
had very little impact on how the
internet actually worked between 2015
and 2017 how that became at Lyford that
scenario just demonstrates the level of
hysteria for people who really don't
understand what the issue is even on the
most basic level I'm not an expert on
that neutrality I don't pretend to be an
expert on net neutrality but the basic
issue is not about the destruction of
the Internet as we know it yeah it's
just patently insane but Jimmy Kimmel
went off on it and and here here he is I
mean Jimmy Kimmel first of all I feel
like every time Jimmy Kimmel speaks
politics now he should be morally
obligated to bring out his baby
tried out his child since he obviously
makes emotional appeals on every he
should what he really should if he's not
gonna bring out his own kid to talk
health care what he really should do
should bring out a poor homeless virgin
street urchin who will no longer be able
to access internet at the public library
for purposes of pornography and he
should just drape his arm around him and
then he should say this poor child will
no longer have internet because of net
neutrality he basically did that last
night just without the poor street
urchin again I don't know what qualifies
Jimmy Kimmel to talk about these things
and I'm happy for Jimmy Kimmel to you
know have a debate with somebody who
knows about it but Jimmy Kimmel doesn't
want to do any of those things he just
wants to read Chuck Schumer agitprop so
here he is the FCC did something
absolutely despicable today devoted to
put an end to net neutrality and this is
the rule that says everyone gets equal
access to the Internet a big company or
somebody selling crocheted owls from
their house in the Midwest now as long
as they tell us they're doing it now
internet service providers will be
allowed to slow down or block web
traffic to any website or streaming
service they like which benefits the big
telecom companies and does the opposite
for all of us but I just wanna say thank
you president Trump thanks to you and
this jackhole you were appointed to run
the FCC he's the jackal it's funny it's
like comedy it's like he's he's a
jackhole so it's comedy now it's not
just political is it cuz he said Jack
Hall get it huh I love Jimmy Kimmel
speaking on behalf of ABC Disney the
biggest corporation in on planet earth
right I mean he's on ABC Disney just
bought Fox Fox 21st century right they
just bought it okay outright Disney is
an enormous corporation and here is
Jimmy Kimmel talking on ABC's airwaves
on what is basically an oligopoly right
ABC was allowed to dominate the airwaves
because it was one of three networks for
most of his history and here he is
talking about all those corporations
they're gonna be controlling everything
those big corporations cuz you know who
doesn't know anything about big
corporations is Jimmy Kimmel right and I
love when he says that like grandma and
her crochet website that's the one
that's gonna pay the price for a net
neutrality being being done away with
the whole point is that Netflix Google
YouTube oppose it not grandma with a
crochet website no one cares about
grandmas crochet website you'd think
that you think that Verizon sitting
around
uh-huh now we got grandma in the cross
hairs we're gonna make her pay up and
she wants her crochet website up there I
got a double her price what absolute
sheer nonsense I know what he's saying
doesn't even make any sense
and it neglects the fact that there are
big corporations on both side of this
like we're gonna have a giant fight Dave
Burge Iowa Hawk had a great tweet on
this he basically said I never thought
that the end of the world was gonna come
over the people who actually provide the
content to social media arguing over who
should benefit from their content
provision the ISPs or the order
companies like Facebook that's really
what it is like the cows are arguing
over who should benefit more over their
provision of the milk the grocery store
the farmer but that's really all this
happening here but it's just it's
insipid and and the level of ire is
totally crazy and P again people don't
know about it like Jimmy Kimmel doesn't
know Dee's talking about here again I'm
not an expert I know more than Jimmy
Kimmel an MSNBC anchor tried to do the
same thing to a former FCC Chairman a
former FCC chairman basically just
stomped on him that's what one of the
arguments for people in favor of
removing net neutrality is that
consumers will get more choice in the
plans that they can buy why would they
get more choice in plans if someone's
not either subsidizing or able to be
excluded from a particular plan why
would I be able to drop what I pay on a
monthly basis for internet if I'm not
gonna lose something for it well let's
rewind the tape a little bit which is
okay so you're talking about consumers
and entrepreneurs and discrimination in
favor of your own product like a Comcast
Pro no that's not what I'm talking about
I think we need to rewind and have this
conversation again at some point because
you're making an argument that I'm not
making I'm saying okay that if someone
has an advantage in streaming their
content over the internet an established
player has an advantage because they've
got the money to be able to buy better
faster quicker access or prevent
somebody else from getting it that the
the incumbent is is favored over the
startup that's the only point I wanted
to make that's the only want to be
illegal that's the point I'm making what
you just said is already illegal it has
been for a long time and we'll be going
forward that's good news not sure you
and I interpreting the same I know
you're good quick bait to say the
Internet's being destroyed but it's not
what I didn't say that that's I don't
know why you're coming on TV but I'm not
having I do see the Internet's being you
just said preferred you did the 73 ISP
if it's preferred if you're favoring one
over another
that's of
this would be this would have been a
much better conversation if we were just
actually having thanks very much Robert
McDowell was he Commissioner from mm I
love that I love that the anchor here
has no idea what he's talking about and
the former FCC chairman keeps saying
it's illegal what you're talking about
already but none of that matters to
anybody the facts don't matter all the
matters of the Jimmy Kimmel is going to
appear on television every night with a
different victim but you can try it out
I think it'd be a great segment by the
way I think you should do victim of the
night right and you should Britt for
every policy you should just bring
somebody out so everything every time
talks tax cuts Jimmy Kimmel should show
up with some poor crippled grandmother
and every time he talks about gun policy
should bring out some some kid who's
been shot in the leg and it would just
be great I think it and then he can cry
over it it'll be it'll be the the
weeping of the of the evening ever every
single time is yeah okay so before I go
any further I'm gonna talk about Russian
investigation fallout president Trump
making a comment this morning that was
rather ill-advised it definitely goes in
the bad Trump in the good Trump bathroom
category we'll talk about all that plus
a little bit of good Trump but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at upside comm so if you travel for
work you owe it to yourself to go to
upside comm you go there right now I
will give you two of the best gifts to
anyone will give you this holiday season
the first is I'm gonna give you the gift
of a better business travel experience I
mean that just comes free and then the
second is a free pair of Bose Soundlink
wireless headphones so you can have some
peace and quiet on your business trip
and that's what you'll get when you book
your next business trip over at upside
comm upside has customer service
specialists who look out for you every
step of the way on your business trip
they have concierge level service
they're hard at work 24/7 to make sure
your flight hotel rental car all go off
without a hitch
they're available on demand by chat
phone and email whenever you need them
only up side monitors your business trip
around the clock they will proactively
keep you updated on everything from the
weather and the city you're going to to
changing your flight home so you can
adjust your meeting schedule there's no
level of experience that is like this at
any of these other competitive travel
sites plus upside has great prices for
flights Hotel and rental cars so again
to get your free pair of Bose Soundlink
web wireless headphones use my code Ben
when you book your first business trip
it upside calm that's code Ben and
upside calm don't forget to use the
promo code don't just skip that window
use that promo code Ben and you get my
free gift to you
those Bose Soundlink wireless headphones
headphones are available while supplies
last
it
must be your first upside purchase and a
$600 minimum purchase is required which
is basically any normal round-trip
flight see the site for complete details
that's code been at upside com use that
code and you get those free Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones a pretty
awesome deal okay so there's more
fallout from the Russian investigation
today that fallout comes in the form of
President Trump and other Republicans
now looking to basically curb the Muller
investigation on the back of Revelations
the people involved in the in the Muller
investigation have a political bias all
their own which honestly we sort of knew
and what you're seeing is that trumps
allies are now coming out of the
woodwork and saying that
Muller needs to pause the probe that
moment needs to stop the probe I said
all along that's actually
counterproductive Muller needs to go
forward with the probe and then when he
comes up with nothing or even if he
comes up with something minor we can all
kick back and say listen guys you you
came up with something minor after a
year of investigation and your team is
corrupt the Clinton was able to do this
very aptly politically speaking with Ken
Starr who did not run a corrupt
investigation and who did come up with
actual perjury right so I don't see the
point in cutting off the investigation
short and yet you're seeing advocates
for Trump basically say this and it
comes off as fear to people who are in
the middle it comes off as fear that
mother's going to find something even if
it really isn't even if it's just that
this investigation is fatally flawed if
something is fatally flawed right if
you've already if you already got shot
the investigation there's no need to
give the head shot in this particular
case I mean Muller has basically he's
these runs investigations a wounded
animal you don't need to put it out of
its misery it's gonna it's gonna die on
its own in any case here's Laura
Ingraham saying that Muller needs to
pause the probe now I'm not calling for
mother Muller to be fired it's tempting
but I'm not but at the very least he
needs to put the brakes on this
investigation at least pause it for a
bit I agree with what Alan Dershowitz
said on my radio show this morning it's
time for a respected independent expert
to come in and thoroughly examine the
individuals conducting this probe and
fire anyone inside who evinces even a
hint of an appearance of a concept this
last call that she's making is the
correct one the last thing that Ingraham
is saying here is absolutely correct Jim
Jordan friendly with representative
Jordan from great state of Ohio
he went after Ron rose
the Deputy Attorney General he said
listen is it time for a second Special
Counsel to look into how Muller is doing
this investigation because maybe what
we're learning now is that half of his
team was compromised you're the guy in
charge
you could disband the Muller special
prosecutor and you can do what we've all
called for appoint a second special
counsel to look into this to look into
Peter struck Bruce or everything else we
have learned in the last several weeks I
mean this is what a lot of Americans are
believing right now and I certainly do
that the Comey FBI and the Obama Justice
Department worked with one campaign to
go after the other campaign that's what
everything points to think about what
we've learned in the last several weeks
we first learned they paid for the
dossier then we learn about Peter struck
and last week we learned about Bruce or
and his wife now I mean this is
unbelievable so what's it going to take
to get a second special counsel to
answer these questions and find out was
Peter struck really up to what I think
he was but that doesn't dismiss the fact
that the country thinks we need a second
special counsel 20 members of this
committee the judiciary Kennedy with
primary jurisdiction over the Justice
Department thinks we need a second
special counsel all kinds of senators
think we need a special counsel and what
fact pattern do you have to have what
kind of text message do you have to see
before you say it's time for a second
special counsel okay so this is I think
a valuable call that's happening I think
it is worthwhile and I think that the
Republicans are doing the right thing
when I don't think is worthwhile is
President Trump
intervening himself so he was asked
today about whether who's gonna pardon
Michael Flynn Michael Flynn of course
the former national security adviser who
has now pled guilty to lying to the FBI
as I've said before I don't think the
Michael Flynn apparently lied to the FBI
about anything substantive from what we
know it sounds like he lied about having
called the Russian government while he
was already in the transition team about
an upcoming UN vote on Israel and
settlements okay I don't see anything
there that that is particularly
noteworthy and I'm not sure why Flynn
lied to the FBI in the first place Trump
may very well want a pardon Flynn but
it's not smart for him to say so because
it looks right now like Flynn is working
with the FBI and so Trump's statement
here than you might pardon Flynn makes
it look like he's trying to bribe Flynn
not to talk to the FBI with a pardon
offer
would you consider a party to Michael
Flynn I don't want to talk about
Cardinal Mike
then yet we'll see what happens let's
see I can say this when you look at
what's going on with the FBI and with
the Justice Department people are very
very angry thank you very much everybody
okay so that is not particularly smart
by the president because now he's open
that can of worms the White House tried
to close that can of worms again today
when Ty Cobb not the great baseball
player with the 367 lifetime average Ty
Cobb the White House lawyer with the
crazy mustache that guy came out and he
said that that trump really has no
intention of pardoning Flynn for the
moment that's the line that Trump needs
to stick to so it doesn't look like he's
obstructing particularly when Vladimir
Putin is doing his best to undermine
Trump's credibility this is one area
where I think Trump really needs to be
more careful Vladimir Putin is playing
this game with Trump he knows Trump's
mentality is that Trump loves praise
Trump responds to praise like if you
toss Trump a Scooby Scooby Snack then he
will he will go investigate crime for
you and you know Vladimir Putin knows
that and so he's acting in that way so
yesterday he came out and he said the
people in the United States should
support President Trump because D
legitimizing Trump undermines the nation
like this is the stuff that Putin's not
saying this because he cares about
America he's doing this because he wants
Trump to do what he wants Trump to do
well that's been mean by the nose you
know that's been invented by those who
are in the opposition people who oppose
President Trump to delegitimize time in
office really seems strange to me
because they don't understand it seems
that the donors stand they undermine
their own nations they limits the powers
of the president has been elected it
means that's so Putin's whole game here
is not that he loves Trump or that he's
trying to help the United States get
through a difficult period in politics
his game is that he's trying to
basically bribe Trump with praise and
from is susceptible to that he then said
to the press today that Vladimir Putin
and he had a very nice call and Putin
told him that he was very happy that
Trump's economy was doing so well like
Putin knows how to play this game it's
foolish of Trump to fall into that and
Trump should
the urge on both on Flynn and on Putin
like just back off at mr. president
especially when you're doing some good
things because the president is doing
some good things okay so yesterday at
the White House the President did a
ceremonial cutting of red tape and it
got made fun of on Twitter a lot but who
cares about what gets everything has
made fun of on Twitter you know
president Trump had all of these papers
stacks of apparently regulations there
were some questions about whether all of
those pages actually had printed
material on them you remember that
President Trump very early on in his
presidency I think it was maybe even
before he took president Heder and
during his transition he brought out a
bunch of folders that he said were all
of his Trump contracts and that he was
going to basically hand those over to
his son and then he was going to
disassociate and then it turned out that
half those folders were filled with
empty paper well I don't know if this
paper was empty or not but it is true
that the president has cut a massive
amount of regulation so yesterday at the
White House he cut a literal red tape
with a giant scissors because this is
the kind of stick we do now in politics
the truth is Trump knows this this is
what Trump is good at the sort of
branding stuff everyone can make fun of
this but if the image is the President
of the United States cutting the red
tape and cutting these regulations that
is good for him right this is good Trump
so he had bad Trump this is good Trump
here was Trump yesterday talking about
how he'd eliminated 22 regulations for
every new regulation added so this is
what we have now and when we're finished
which won't be in too long a period of
time we will be less than where we were
in 1960 and we will have a great
regulatory climate to do with it she has
things called rose
that's a big and bridges right yes okay
with all the wild enthusiasm of youth
the president Rome cuts that it cuts
that ribbon one two three pretty
spectacular stuff it is mop worthy but
it is also true the President of the
United States has cut a lot of
regulations one of the reasons the stock
market is doing well one of the reasons
the economy is very hot last quarter was
a three percent three point three
percent GDP growth and not only that the
Fed is raising the rates again so the
Fed has been tightening up the monetary
flow inflation is is going to be brought
under control and the economy continues
to be strong some of that is on
President Obama and the Republican
Congress before Trump but obviously
there's a lot of confidence in how the
economy is working right now and that is
at least in large part due to president
Trump's that is good stuff and this is
the area where Trump really could
succeed this is why it's actually deeply
important that the president work on his
popularity rating I know a lot of people
don't care about this I know a lot of
people aren't worried about his
popularity they think oh well he can
have bad poll numbers and as long as
he's doing well we're happy he needs to
get his poll numbers up because a lot of
the things he's doing are things I like
there are things that I agree with a lot
of his agenda mirrors my own I think
that's wonderful but if you take my
agenda and then you smear poop all over
it
right if you take my agenda and you take
your unpopularity and you smear my
agenda with unpopularity it makes my
agenda toxic that's not worthwhile okay
you should not make your own agenda
toxic this way and that's why it's very
important that the president should be
focusing in on his own accomplishments
like a laser he should be focusing in on
the things he's doing like a laser he
should not be making himself more
unpopular with foolish statements like
the one that he made today about Mike
Flynn he should not be engaging on
Twitter as much honest to God if
somebody unplugged the man's phone and
it's just the battery ran down Lord of
Comcast decided to cut off Twitter but
just for the White House then the then
the the his popularity ratings would
jump rather dramatically because the
fact is the Democrats have nothing here
right Nancy Pelosi was saying that the
GOP like she's trying to make the case
the GOP tax bill is a Pyrrhic victory
that it's going to end the Republicans
there has never been a tax reduction in
history that has rebounded to the
negative effect of Republicans ever it
does not work that way
well we stayed united and we
we still continue that fight I think
this is a Pyrrhic victory if it in fact
it does happen we don't have the votes
to take it down and as some of the
Republicans see the light and people are
speaking out especially since they added
the repeal of the mandate the Affordable
Care Act individual mandate that has
energized the base further but this is
who they are this is what they came here
to do tax cuts for the rich at the
expense of the middle class at the
expense of the hill this is all empty it
doesn't work Democrats have been trying
this for years all the anti tax cut
rhetoric is a bunch of nonsense and and
so that's why if Trump's agenda where
the main focus here as opposed to
whatever Trump says today he'd be doing
a lot better and so with the
conservative agenda he's been a lot more
conservative than I thought he would be
as president this is not how he campaign
I'm very pleased with that but I want to
see all of that at the top of the page
not all of the other nonsense that seems
to cloud our judgment okay so I have a
lot to get to today we have the mailbag
today things I like things I hate still
a lot on the docket here but for all of
that you're gonna have to go over and
subscribe it's a Lee Weyer com so for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
today Lee Weyer calm when you do you not
only get my show live you get the rest
of the enric Levens show live against
the rest of Michael Moses show live and
it can be part of the mailbag we're
gonna be doing that in just a minute you
get to ask questions only if you are a
subscriber and then you go over to daily
wire and you can type in your questions
and we'll answer them live from you
today
so $9.99 a month gets you that
subscription if you want this the
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr then
all you have to do is pay $99 a year so
cheaper than the monthly subscription
and you get all of those affirmation
wonderful things plus you get discounts
at the Shapiro store as well when you
become a member if you just want to
listen later iTunes SoundCloud Google
Play stitch or any of the podcast apps
we are available on plus please
subscribe over at youtube to our channel
because we have some new videos coming
out one we filmed yesterday is patently
absurd but you will definitely want to
see it I'm not gonna give any clues
because it would give away the joke but
suffice it to say there will be images
of me that I would rather not be on the
Internet
that will be available probably next
week when you not those kind of interest
people click get your mind out of the
gutter but you go over to did good
YouTube and subscribe we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty time for a quick thing I like
and then a thing I hate and then we'll
get to the mailbag so the thing that I
like today I've been doing Beethoven all
week so this is one of my dad's favorite
pieces this is Beethoven sonata opus 111
the reason that I picked this is not
only because it's fun but this
particular segment of the Beethoven
if you don't hear snidely whiplash in
here like Beethoven is so modern that
when you listen to his music especially
his late music what you will hear is all
of these film references that you never
had thought about before and you will
hear where they came from so this is
basically it sounds like snidely
whiplash there's no way around it it
sounds like Nellas is tied to the tracks
and Dudley do-right is gonna show up so
here it is from sonata opus 111 from
Beethoven
[Music]
that's the thing that Beethoven is if
you actually listen to a lot of
Beethoven his range is just astonishing
and some of the concerts that he has so
Beethoven started off as a concert
pianist everybody thinks that he's
famous for being a composer he started
off like Mozart as a performer he was
world famous I mean he was famous across
Europe he was mostly famous for
improvisation so everybody thinks of
classical music as being very staid and
it's all written on the page as opposed
to jazz which is improvisational but
Beethoven was very very famous for being
the greatest improviser of his age and
you can tell that in his development
sections in his pieces which I talked
about yesterday
but they're famous stories of him they
would basically have improvisation offs
like they would actually have a couple
of pianists in a room one person would
improvise and the other person would
have to do something cooler with
improvisation there's a famous story
about Beethoven where he was in a bad
mood one day and somebody invited him to
one of these parties and want him to
play and he was not into it and he lost
to some guys the only time he'd ever
lost he's sort of undefeated and there
and then the guy called for a rematch
and in the rematch the guy who he was
improvident he was improvising against
that guy made a mistake he took one of
beethoven's themes and started
improvising off one of Beethoven's
themes his way to mock Beethoven the guy
had also premiered a new piece of his
Beethoven went over to the the cellist
in the new piece took the cellist music
turned it upside down and then
improvised off the guy's music upside
down and so that's how Alan sent a
musician Beethoven was the you can't say
enough about about the greatness of
Beethoven's genius okay time for a
couple of things I hated the Mogul
mailbag okay so first thing that I hate
there's this video going around
yesterday that's just insane a lot of
the a lot of the northern European
countries have gotten very into
euthanasia oh and I say that I don't
mean that they've legalized euthanasia I
mean that they have actually started
advocating for euthanasia for people who
are mentally handicapped they've
advocated for euthanasia for people who
are depressed
they've relieved restrictions on
euthanasia this is doctor assisted
suicide of course and this video if this
doesn't you know scream a Nazi to you
it's because you don't know enough about
the Nazis here's a Dutch government
official telling a Down Syndrome man
that he's too expensive how much he
costs the state to be living to be a
live here is here's this video it's
pretty astonishing
says 48 thousand euro per year
approximately
their donor per downer or down-syndrome
person this short ghost so short cost us
as a society 48 thousand euros per year
for your considerable amount but is it a
high one compared to normal person well
you can calculate that by taking the big
number that 90 billion and divide this
amount by the number of citizens in the
Netherlands and there are approximately
seventeen billion and that will give you
approximately the amount of five
thousand euros per year per person so
you could say that short is almost ten
times as expensive then we are those
expenses are indeed ten times as high
you are a valuable man short okay the
reason that this is creepy folks is if
you look back at the Nazi eugenics
programs this is how they all started
look back at the campaign of 1932 one of
the things the nazis were saying is
there are a bunch of people in our
society or the undesirables and they
cost the government too much money they
cost the government too much money for
upkeep and if there were only something
we could do with them if there are only
something that could do with all these
very expensive people it costs a lot of
money to keep them alive mm-hmm and
there's always a creepy Prelude either
these are people who deserve our help or
there are people who don't deserve our
help they're human beings they can't
take care of themselves they deserve our
help falling into this trap is is the
essence of evil but this is also what
socialism ends toward right when the
government is quote-unquote paying
people to live then it's pretty and
private charity withers then it's it's
only a matter of time before the
government starts thinking of ways out
of this particular conundrum okay so
final thing that I hate today
so I'm mark Stein I thought made a point
that is worth noting with regard to
sexual harassment is getting all sorts
of flack for it but this is a point that
I've made - when we talk about sexual
harassment and sexual assault we need to
be very specific about what it is that
we are talking about because vague
standards actually hurt women they not
only hurt women by conflating sexual
harassment with non sexual harassment or
conflating mild sexual harassment
meaning a guy says something crude in
the workplace to rape but they also ends
up making it they given a reverse
incentive for employers to actually hire
women in much the same way that the
Americans with Disabilities Act which
forced business business owners
to buildin ramps in their places of
business if they hired a disabled person
caused a lot of business owners not to
hire disabled people make their actual
statistics that bear that out in the
same way this idea that sexual
harassment is gonna be vaguely defined
and we're going to destroy the career of
anybody who's ever accused of anything
is going to encourage men to hire only
other men so they're not accused of this
sort of stuff Mark Steyn makes this
point yesterday do I really want to be
alone with a female employee now think
that oh who knows yeah who knows how
she's gonna feel about it in 30 years
time I mean I don't think that's
necessarily in the interests of women in
the workplace I don't think it's in the
interests of social relations it's an
insane moral panic that started with
genuine rape genuine violence genuine
power issues and now just seems so
degenerated into one anonymous
accusation can end a career well this is
why we have to be very careful and
that's why we have to be very specific
about what accusations we're gonna hold
to you know I've said this over and over
and over sexual harassment is is evil
sexual abuse is evil but we need to be
very clear about what we're talking
about and what kind of accusations we're
going to take with with the proper
amount of severity otherwise the the
actual effect will be people making the
kinds of decisions you don't want them
to make saying I'm not gonna hire that
woman because if I hire her then I'm
afraid she's going to accuse me of
sexual harassment at some point down the
line that may be unjustified that is the
way people act okay time for the mailbag
so Kaitlyn says hi Ben I read on your
Fox News power player of the week
article they do you initially want it's
a double major in genetic science and
music what brought you to deciding on
political science and then law school
thanks Caitlin so what actually brought
me to political science is two things
one I tried an engineering class a math
engineering class and I did okay in it I
was getting a name I think I was getting
an A up till the final and then I ended
up with a B in the class I believe but
in any case I was like that's enough of
that that was one thing now the other
thing that happened is that I was
walking through the UCLA campus and I
picked up the UCLA daily Bruin which was
a far left rag and there was a piece in
it comparing then the Israeli Prime
Minister of Israel Ariel Sharon to Adolf
Eichmann the Nazi and I walked into the
offices and said do you mind if I write
a counter to this and they said sure and
then that became a counterpoint column
and I realized that this is something
I'm much more interested in then
then you know doing all of the things
necessary to become an expert in
genetics it's not that I wasn't
interested in the topic I just wasn't
willing to slog through that mud and I
have nothing but admiration for people
who do I mean for the 1000 times my wife
is a doctor which means that she is
still basically doing she's residency
now right I mean she's been doing this
since we met it married for 10 years and
she's 10 years in July and she and yet
she is still you know doing this so
that's that's a long haul Morgan says
when you were a child how do your
parents encourage you to practice the
violin how do you prove to a child
there's a long term benefit to playing
an instrument well it's very difficult
to prove to a small trial there's a
long-term benefits playing the
instrument you have to make it fun one
of the things that was of advantage to
me is that my father was a professional
musician so he would sit there with the
piano and play with me you actually need
to sit there and practice with your kid
you need to be involved
it's boring it may not be fun for you
but if your kid knows that you're
willing to put in the time then your kid
assumes that you are willing also to do
that only for things that are important
plus kids want to spend time with their
parents and if you're willing to spend
time with your kid practicing even if
you are not you know even even if you're
not musically vers then your kid will
take it a lot more seriously you can't
just tell a kid go practice for half an
hour you actually need to sit there with
the kid and I think if you're willing to
do that then your kid will be more
likely to practice also when you get to
a certain level it does become enjoyable
at the very beginning it's kind of fun
because something new and then there's a
plateau that gets hit where it becomes
very difficult and then when you get
good enough then it's a lot of fun again
because you're skilled okay al says hey
Ben coming from the UK which has health
care for all but to my mind is
struggling to pay for it your arguments
on health care supply interest me
greatly I like the American idea that
the market is used to drive down costs
but at the same time according to the
Commonwealth Fund the US government
spends way more on health care than most
major countries it has the lowest
quality of care in terms of outcomes
equity and access whereas the UK has the
highest even though we're close to
rationing the system is so expensive
what in your mind is the best system for
countries with huge populations like the
UK and us who solved the health care
crisis given they both spend too much
but socialized health care seems to
produce better results well it depends
on the results that you are seeking so
number one socialized medicine has
pretty good emergency care but they have
not great surgical care in the sense
that you have to wait around in line for
the rationing to actually take place the
five-year survival rate for cancer in
the United States is significantly
higher than it is in places like the UK
specifically because I can go and get
the care that I
now instead of having to sit around and
wait healthcare on demand is you know a
market driven health care system is
great but it requires the patient to
actually do the research and because of
the insurance companies that provide a
barrier between you and the doctor and
you don't actually know what you're
paying through the doctor because your
insurance company covers it you end up
ordering more services than are
necessary and in many cases so does your
doctor right if you are actually forced
to sit there and say okay is it worth an
x-ray today
right is it worth $1,000 for an x-ray or
I can go home and wait for a week you
probably go home and wait for a week
there actually isn't perfect market para
transparency in the United States and
that causes a serious problem in terms
of the meet between supply and demands
in terms of medical care in the United
States when these measures where they
say that the US has the lowest quality
of care in terms of the outcomes equity
at access well I mean when you talk
about access basically socialized
medicine will always have the highest
access because people can walk into a
hospital and demand service or to a
doctor's office and demand service they
don't have the highest outcomes in terms
of the rate at which those services are
provided and in terms of outcomes again
it sort of depends on which outcomes
you're looking at you can't say outcomes
overall also the UK population is not
really comparable to the United States
either in terms of size or diversity
McDaniel says are there any elections in
American history you would have found
yourself voting Democrat over a
Republican well you know that's that's
I'd have to think about that one a
little bit more I'm trying to think back
to a time when the Democratic Party in
the Republican Party we're sort of
reverses of what they are now I think
that in 1948 I would have to seriously
consider Truman versus Dewey I think
that that would probably be the only one
that I'd be that I'd be interested in
looking at seriously
perhaps 56 Adlai Stevenson versus
Eisenhower I might have looked at that
one more seriously mainly because I
think Eisenhower's foreign policy with
regard to the Suez Canal crisis which
really happened and at the tail end of
his first term that that would have been
a problem for me so I think that that's
a you know those two races but I don't
know I'd really have to study those more
to determine how I would have come out
whether I really would have voted for
the Democrat over the Republican in
those races anastasiya says hi Ben
I work with a bunch of liberals that
hate God one person in particular has
zero respect for God my belief in God or
just musique human being in general
she'll ask zero questions about God and
then mock my answer this individual is a
supervisor if you're going to HR upper
management in case of retaliation losing
my job how should I handle this well you
should stop interacting I mean frankly
it's it's not worth every interaction
that may make things chilly keep things
professional keep things like don't talk
about God if they mock God just say
listen I find that offensive and and you
know that you don't I don't deserve to
have my belief system on I don't mock
your belief system and if they have a
problem with that tough but I don't
think that professionalism in the
workplace seems to me a bare minimum no
matter what your political viewpoint
Jeremy says I bet you've been critical
about Democrats and Republicans accused
of sexual assault even going so far as
to call for Roy Moore to drop out now
Franken to resign where do you stand on
Trump's allegations and how do they
differ from the above-mentioned senators
should Trump resign too so what I've
said is an ideal world everyone who has
credible allegations of sexual assault
and abuse should resign and everyone and
in an ideal world that would include the
president but there is a difference in
kind between the Roy Moore situation in
the Al Franken situation and Trump the
difference in kind is this and not with
regard to the allegations regard with
regard to the practicality of saying
they should resign there's one giant
obstacle that is Roy Moore was running
an election the people did not elect him
okay so that's that
Al Franken people didn't know this
information when they elected him so now
it's new information breaking and that
changes the calculation as to whether he
should resign all the allegations
against Trump are old people know about
it when they elected him nothing new has
been added to the pie
therefore it's difficult to say that on
the basis of nothing changing he should
now resign
that's like saying he should have quit
during the election cycle which by the
way I believe I said during the election
cycle in the middle of the p-word tape
so that is that's that's my general take
like an ideal world sure in the real
world
not really Danielle says they used to
laugh at the idea of born-again virgins
however after listening to you and the
importance he placed on entering into
marriages virgins I became sad that I
could no longer offer this as a non
virgin what can I do to bring a sense of
innocence to a future marriage do you
believe the remaining abstinence until
marriage affects the success of the
relationship I do think that remaining
abstinence until marriage affects the
success of relationships generally
meaning that people who live together
before marriage have a significantly
higher divorce rate than people who
don't live together before marriage and
usually once you're living with a
certain level of intimacy sexually you
end up living together before you were
married and that does not actually end
up reflecting married
married life is not you living together
with your boyfriend married life is you
have kids you have a joint bank account
you have responsibilities those are not
always reflected in just you living with
your boyfriend even with the advent of
single motherhood I think that the idea
of born-again marriage the Virgin's the
idea that that you were you've had sex
but now with your new partner you're
gonna say no sex until marriage I think
that's a worthwhile thing because it's
asking just practically speaking it's
asking for a commitment before you
decide to commit your body to somebody
and I think that that is a smart play I
think then it's a smart play I think
it's a demand for a commitment that
should easily be met by a good person
right the fact that we there are so many
TV shows now where they've reversed
everything it's really it's funny how
this worked it used to be that when I
grew up my parents said to me when you
get married then you'll have sex and
then it turned into when people talk to
their kids I said when we love somebody
you have sex and now it's turned into
you'll have sex and then you figure out
whether you love somebody and when you
watch TV this is what you see you see
two people hop into bed and then they'll
be real awkward about whether to say I
love you or not so this idea that
somehow love has been more closely tied
to sex with the disconnection between
sex and marriage is absolutely false in
fact love has become less connected to
sex sex was much more connected with
love when love was connected to
commitment so I think we've completely
reversed the polarity on sex love and
marriage Robert says hey man my
girlfriend has a very small family I
have a very large family she has asked
me previously about taking on her
family's last name because if I told her
dad will likely be the last to hold it I
want to hold on to my last name I also
don't know why I should seemingly be
selfish and have her give it give it up
what is your advice and what are your
thoughts on last names so when when I
got married my wife seriously considered
keeping her last name as her middle name
so her maiden name is Toledano she
seriously thought about keeping that as
her middle name when we went to like and
I was fine with that because my mom did
the same thing she kept her maiden name
as her middle man it never bothered me I
never thought that was a big deal as
long as she took my last name which I
the reason I think that's important is
because I think that it is important
that a family that a family start on the
footing of we are a new family now we
are our own family or our own family
unit and the reason that I think that
it's important for I think it is sort of
emasculating for men maybe it's a
cultural totem but I think it's
emasculating for men to give up their
family name the idea that a man is
supposed to give up you know that what
what he has grown up with in favor of
the woman's family can be emasculating
if you don't find it emasculating I
don't
problem with it if you do finding it
emasculating then I do see a problem
with it so this is really between you
and the person that you're married to yo
for me my wife said to me listen she was
thing about keeping that middle name she
decided not to she decided to just go
with her first nation didn't have a
middle name she decide to go with her
first name and my last name because she
said listen we're now our own family we
are our own family unit I want to be
part of that family unit with you it was
very moving to me frankly and I think
it's something that I really appreciate
it is gift from her to me it's not
something I had to expect but it's
something that I certainly appreciate it
okay Joe says what is the most
infuriating debate tactic used against
you and how do you combat it well always
the most infuriating debate tactic is
when someone will dig something up 10
years old take it out of context and
then use it against you and then refuse
to hear the answer that's always
infuriating because context matters and
things that you said in 2007 maybe not
may not be things that you agree with
today and things that you tweeted in
2012 may not be things that are even
taken in context so for me for example
there's been a tweet that people have
been using against me on Twitter for a
long time with regard to Arabs and
Israelis in which I said something to
the effect of Israelis like to build and
Arabs like to live in open sewage the
idea of that tweet was not that every
Arab likes to live in open sewage you
morons the idea of that tweet is that in
the israeli-arab conflicts there is one
side that likes to build things and one
side that would prefer to spend its
money on building terror tunnels in the
Gaza Strip instead of actually caring
for its people and in fact not only am i
saying that now I said that in 2012
there are four follow-up tweets I
believe and all of them said exactly
that doesn't matter people take that
tweet out of context and then they use
that to say that I'm racist against
Arabs which is absurd in that same tweet
thread I specifically say that there are
Muslim Arabs and Christian Arabs who are
wonderful people just not the ones who
side with terror groups like Hamas but
again that's just an example of how
people take things out of context and
then use them against you and that I
find it highly irritating david says do
you feel everyone speaks too slowly yes
yes everyone speaks too slowly they are
wasting my time it's why I listen to the
podcasts that I listen to I actually had
to download an app that allows me to
listen to podcasts at 2.5 so I listened
to all the podcast that I listened to a
2.5 I guess the maximum is 3 it depends
on whose podcasting if somebody's a very
slow speaker then 3 is the proper speed
I hear that it's difficult to listen to
my podcast on 2 or were even 1.5 but for
those who who are willing to take the
the Speed Challenge go for it Michael's
has been I've been deeply inspired by
your devotion to your religion and
dedication to the nation I'm a person
raised Christian but I rejected the
church and have been living as an
atheist for the last fifteen years as a
veteran fighting PTSD I found that our
Bible talk was leading me to read the
Torah and I've been more optimistic than
I have been in years I want to know more
about converting to Judaism and what
your advice would be for a person living
in a deeply Christian community Bible
Belt coal country with absolutely no
Jewish community to turn to is there a
place I can find mentorship and what is
the view of the Jewish community on
conversion so Jewish law generally
actually discourages conversion because
it's not the world's easiest life right
now that to convert you have to convert
Orthodox from the Orthodox point of view
and that means that you have to take
upon yourself all the obligations not
working on Sabbath making sure that you
eat kosher right you're supposed to
commit to everything because if you're
gonna commit commit right that's the
basic idea here so we actually tell
people if somebody wants to convert we
actually turn them down three times
where we're actually halakhah cailli
according to Jewish law obligated to
turn them down three times before we're
allowed to say yes as far as mentorship
you know I think there are a lot of
rabbis who can be talked to who are
really good on this if you want to email
me directly I can probably refer you to
some if this is something that you want
to take seriously or find out more about
it's gonna be very difficult for you to
live as a as an observant Jew in an area
where there no other Jews because so
many Jewish commitments are communal
right it's about the nation of Israel
and Judaism not just the individual who
has a relationship with God in the Torah
but I'd be happy to pass on some names
for you Daniel says hey been caught your
talk in San Francisco this weekend and
thought you did a good job here's my
question if you are concede Sam's point
about free will that low producing
people or even criminals are entirely
products of their biological
predisposition and environment would you
still think that the best mindset or
policies for maximizing human well-being
are ones that promote and empower
self-reliance over support from the
government so the answer is that the
answer is yes but I think the entire
thing becomes a giant self contradiction
so one of the big problems here is that
if you are living in a determinist
universe even the question as to what
policies the government should pursue
assumes a certain level of freewill on
the part of government actors to
actually change the policies if this is
my big problem with with Sam's take on
freewill is once you say this once
you're living in a fully deterministic
universe then to say then I'm going to
do what I was going to do right the idea
of me even getting up in the morning and
going to do things I was going to do
that so it's not like I make the choice
to do that or I make the choice to
support certain
policies I was going to support those
policies all along and I had no choice
in that process it's it's the computer
fries itself in other words all of human
progress relies on the idea that we have
a capacity to discover what's true about
the universe and that we have a capacity
to make better policy that frees people
all of that is based on free will and
the capacity for choice you get rid of
all that this is the this is the basic
question that I kept asking Sam and I'm
not sure that I got an answer that
satisfied me at the very least I kept
saying to him you know Sam you talk a
lot about changing the world and you
talked a lot about using active verbs
making choices but you don't believe in
those choices you talked a lot about
moral values and what those that value
systems should be making a value
decision is a choice about hierarchy of
values how do you make that decision you
can't get from is to all you can't get
from we are balls of meat wandering
aimlessly through the universe with some
capacity for self perception with the
idea that there is a moral system that
makes certain things more worthwhile
than others you can't get from here is a
cup to what should I do with this cup
unless there was a creator of the cop
who had in mind what the cup is for
right that's the point that I was making
my philosophy bridges the is odd gap
this is what Aristotle does Aristotle
says what makes a man good is that man
was created for a certain purpose once
you get rid of purpose once you get rid
of design once you get rid of the idea
of meaning I don't know how you
reconstruct anything that looks like a
functional society Ben says hi Ben I was
reading an article you retweeted from
National Review about how America's
youth are lonely are less independent
and less attached to community I
understand that much of this couldn't be
applied to me how does someone who
desperately wants to break this rather
nihilist youth mentality go about doing
it engage the answer is engaged get
active they can sit there and you can
contemplate it or you can go in to
involve yourself with other people it's
hard I know it's especially hard when
you're a single guy I remember being a
single guy before I was married marriage
is a wonderful thing I love being
married when I was a single guy I did
not enjoy being single because it takes
actual effort to go out and engage with
other human beings you actually have to
go out and make an effort to join a
group go out and do it it'll make your
life better those social engagements
will make you more apt to open up to
others and that will enrich your
experience in life Holden says hi Ben
huge fan I go to a liberal school have
to debate income inequality next week
I've gotten in trouble for speaking my
opinions before I'm a little scared can
give me some pointers on how to debate
income inequality well I mean the number
one thing that I always say about income
inequality is that what level of their
two things
number one what level of income equality
would be sufficient for you and why so
for Bernie Sanders why shouldn't
everyone make $40,000 a year that seems
the fairest thing right why not be full
communist seize all the property
redistribute it everybody gets the same
thing why not is it really fair that
someone should make more than somebody
else and why how do you make that
decision put the onus on the person to
explain what level of income inequality
is bad versus what level of income
inequality is good second it does not
hurt you the Bill Gates is rich right
Bill Gates being rich is actually good
for you because it's Bill Gates wealth
that brought about all of these
consensual transactions in which you
take place every time you buy a loaf of
bread from the grocer you are making the
grocer richer would you prefer not to be
able to buy the loaf of bread you've
created more income inequality because
you just spent money with the grocer you
were poorer he's richer are you both
worse off are you both better off the
answer is you're both better off okay
final question Romney says I said I know
you said hip-hop isn't music
are there any hip-hop songs or artists
that you have at least somewhat enjoyed
no I it a short answer is no I feel like
there's probably some hip-hop that I
might enjoy on a visceral level but I
have not yet found it maybe that's
because I let my app my Apollonian side
dominate my Diane Asian side too much in
the in sort of Nietzsche and
juxtaposition so maybe that's a little
sophisticated for a hip-hop breakdown
but there you are okay so we will be
back here next week we'll be back here
on Monday I hope you have a wonderful
and a meaningful weekend if you're
celebrating Hanukkah I hope that you're
having a wonderful Konica if you're
celebrating Christmas I hope you're
having a wonderful time getting prepared
for Christmas in any case have a great
weekend I'm entropy ro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zingara audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2017